so we doing EVP nuggets and we're
getting rid of and now I remember that
katate dori is a particular plane
through which a force vector is
traveling and it's an equivalent to a
straight punch homologous paper okay so
we've been doing Godot well Joe diamonds
upper-level so solar plexus ah so this
would be a straight punch it could be a
knife so now we have to figure out how
do I get it to move over so that I can
find that back corner you might want to
get it out it's not possible and then
you're gonna do this one but this is
even worse now okay
so first let's lose the traditional ski
range so he's waiting back there right
and then he steps through with his ski
like whoa right because it's not not
teach us anything but to sit down wait
for the start okay so we're gonna move
it closer and see we're in here he's
still got a step through because he
still needs to spinal disengagement okay
but I'm going to meet him just like in
the other one
imagine him I created the connection
early so when we were here like this
like
connection order and now the eternal
game skills come into play because if I
push them away right you're not going to
get it you have to absorb them in okay
so he goes you'll push on you you'll
yield look what I was going first
watch the technique one two three
this hand goes in first see then you'll
feel the pressure
then you'll yield it you'll pass it to
the other hand does he call on the
outside so won't yield boom he'll order
Missha conversation
did we attack the head face
don't start so far out you're fine boom
so watch we'll go slow
watch what should I do so there's
friction here I'm not just letting it go
relax relax relax
are you pulling it with that friction
and I do the same thing with the other
so you're gonna feel like when I get
here is I'm kind of underneath that's
not good so that's where the other hand
kicks up to continue the friction right
here do not mistake it for letting the
punch go by okay there is an IT
connection because you need that extra
half-inch okay so you comes in boom
[Music]
let's just look at that narrative so a
guy who's aggressive so I'm regressing
then I feel the pressure
he's thing and instead of sitting here
income and contesting I would yield fool
to get the Hat so remember the you're
here at the head so we've seen the same
mistake where you're like just self
defense stuff and he goes here you are
so the first one does not go here
because I'm not interested in you Caston
is I'm interested in engaging he goes
pull deaths what am i doing you see so
trying to understand your test of Aki is
very much cruise a lot of oh you
guys have this wax on wax off so who
pushes let it go engage
[Music]
that's why we're not ready push push
there don't worry
you just go push
rollin like this
get your head inside
[Music]
it's gonna turn into do you
understand
okay so do I just move my arms is there
only an external aspect to the art so
say do you have anything going on
internally
no you just moving the arms that's why
you're pushing them away he needs to get
stuck to you there needs to be an IT and
easy so well just he's going to push
okay I want you to know where he is in
space do you see his ease up but you see
I came forward in my arm room no but the
relaxation in there gives me enough
extra inch
okay so relaxation is not his strikes
coming in around relaxing that's not it
again right can you push on it no he
can't do you see I come in can you push
on it no there's an integrity to it but
watch you see do you see I got the extra
edge okay then you're going to have to
have some sort of reorganization in your
body so it's not just a relaxation video
for your arm your body's gotta release
so when he comes in I'm here look look
at my frame you see it now as he comes
in look wait shifty backwards do you see
boom relaxation boom pop this is like
you guys with money you see he's away
from me so contact absorb Holderness
you can basically what you're doing this
it's your only oxide or but I need the
inside so engage this is me taking the
slack out of the relationship
so usually rootkit takes the slack out
you see that but here I take this left
out slack these out now I have an
energetic possibility hole take this
lockout slack out whoa look at my body
[Music]
we were Thomas slow down so you're not
so triggered okay let's switch
[Music]
which way is he going here
here I'm still going straight forward
right still forward okay watch the
difference
over 400 said and this is where your
knees Jackie laughs okay so let me use
him patience so I'm not going here to do
this I need to go around me so there has
to be gravity to me that's five that's
bad meet you
so he comes in you see it's right here
here's where he's pushing and I make you
see now when I enter and turn right so
I'm going to take this energy away you
see so it's exact opposite
I'm not going here here I love the
second arm it's right here
then I yield on the second arm boom
that's what brings in debt do you guys
see that
so let's just slow down pressure out
comes in low the second arm there it is
right then you do the footwork oh you
guys okay let's try and slow it down
just enough so internally they're
fielding internally but externally
there's a say but I can't just
externally yield I always try to tell
you there is it and Ephesian that's
happening but that's that's what I'm
demonstrating when I'm here like that
okay so he is if i push like that you
can you can see that you can punch oh
don't hit me in the face but if I push
on him but if I stay in this perfect
thing there's enough friction of his key
for me to for me the two things I don't
need to have superpowers I just need
that extra quarter inch
after finishing you see so you can't
push into him past that and I need that
relaxation so he absorbs into me
okay but I can't have it be where I'm
here like this and you're like relax you
see there's no structural integrity here
so internally I am relaxing but right
here I have the same thing you see you
can push into him so when I move around
do you see how it's doing this so again
to say thing if I extend it it's fine if
I extend it off it is Center but I'm not
putting the extended I'm going to keep
the friction by turning so I load up
that arm and when I turn look what I see
you see
so just like the plot said you're not
relying on that turning of his arm
because that would not protect the
integrity of the radius so you set up
the other arm you create the internal
and Eva and he's pushing on me he's
actually UCB for violence and it's when
I take it away
so again boom wall there it is right
there
I move around it and he falls on much I
take it away so it's a mixture of them
falling on it and him having just enough
friction that I keep them in it okay
so what I see now is your into your
internal relaxation has an external
compromise a shoe okay let's go
[Music]
two more
that's your side take the pressure out
at the beginning I reach from him reach
reach you're waiting engage engage
engage in game there you go
engage two more engaged go and then you
got to do the same thing you engage you
don't wait
[Music]
we're always trying to be moving okay
and the guy attacked me
this is stupid to be here on this
fencing line so the guy tracks me right
and I'm already trying to circle around
I'm trying to generate the spiral that
spiral geometry because this linear mind
does nothing for me especially if he's
armed or trying to deploy a weapon or if
he's bigger than me in any of the BA but
the spiraling geometry helps me in all
of those cases so we're trying to figure
out how to get back well you don't
understand what you're feeling razza up
so now have a training scarring you you
thinking X Y but you didn't pay
attention to all the GUI that I've done
on you I never X Y never XY XY means I
up okay for a lawyer code you got
the beating that you have coming sorry
okay so that's why you're so prone to
taking this as a response and then X Y Z
C and then I go over here so this next
one remember katate dori is just a
particular plane to home elaborate plane
and then the linear vector so tackle is
the same thing or just him
she do you see how we're doing that so
let's not get there yet but let's take
the punch again right wolf
and this time look I'm going to yield
with the every spinal elbow so we
engaged he goes right there's that usher
point I wouldn't go around with you guys
so I H hold there this wool wool you'll
feel it right there around it here we go
push push push push
integrity integrity
[Music]
and again it's the evening that has been
coming forward so he's not sitting there
he's not putting here and then I go to
him bow back rainfall center must
continue flowing
okay you're out feel the pressure right
it's the same circle the same circles
you see we're over here now you see that
so load the arm there it is and then
when you go over you see you're out here
like this you're going to do these
triangle steps doesn't it feel Torquay
Yahoo are you wanna that's what you do
you only see that in touch you okay so
oh there it is load it let it come in
full you already because you're on a
circle Hey you see all right left arm
left leg forward you don't have to make
this cross level okay so that there were
external tai sabaki requirement is help
when you realize in my XY or my starting
to generate